the trump administration is suing the
president's former national security
adviser john bolton to stop the
publication of a tell-all book
bolton's memoir the room where it
happened is an inside look at his time
in the white house and it's due to be
published next tuesday
by simon schuster a division of c viacom
cbs
the administration argues that this book
contains classified information
chief washington correspondent major
garrett joins us major good morning very
few people have seen this book
so it's hard to talk about what's in it
but how is bolton responding
well bolton and the publishers say this
is a transparent effort to censor them
and not a particularly legally
sophisticated one it's also highly
personal
the justice department lawsuit doesn't
sue the publisher or seek a temporary
restraining order to block publication
but it does seek revenue
from bolton and puts all the burden on
him from stopping this publication
meaning it's highly personal which is
the way the white house views this book
itself
as an act of animosity bordering on
betrayal from a former senior official
who worked closely with the president
it's all about the pre-clearance process
which bolton and the publishers say they
went through
thought they had a green light then it
suddenly stopped and that stopping they
assert
is a transparent effort by the white
house to block publication of this book
until after the election
because the white house knows it's
potentially damaging we're
also it's important to note that on
monday the president said
he considers any conversation with him
to be highly classified
that is not a legal standard most
lawyers in this field
recognize or validate
yeah that is pretty broad major okay so
to the book itself
what do we expect bolton to reveal in it
well bolton says this book will show in
detail the president's
chaotic leadership style that he treats
allies rougher than
enemies and that most of his foreign
policy decisions
are driven by re-election desires now
the public has a general sense of this
but this could be much more detailed
it's worth pointing out tony that the
former national security adviser could
have testified
to congress about the ukraine matter and
bolton tantalizingly says there are
other matters like ukraine he will
divulge in his book but he never did
he said he would respond to a subpoena
from senate republicans in the
impeachment trial
that never came bottom line he could
have testified under oath
now he's got a book out there possibly
for profit
yeah and the question will be is it for
profit or out of a matter of
principle i guess the public will decide
if they ever see it major garrett thank
you very much